here in the desert outside of downtown
Doha there isn't a football to be seen
there is though a World Cup taking place
one with only five nations taking part
in one of qatar's oldest and most unique
Sports camel racing
the camels here are written by robot
jockeys who are controlled by their
owners who ride alongside them during
the race in four by fours
the camels race at speeds of up to 40
miles per hour as their operator applies
the whip antenna commands the jockey to
pull on the reins and shouts
encouragement via a built-in speaker
it's racing in the 21st century and it's
bringing in the tourists
we have seen a large number of FIFA fans
come in here to enjoy the race and we're
doing our best to introduce him to our
traditions and culture
every year the race changes involves
with time the prices are Beyond big and
this is why we have a huge participation
from all the countries in the GCC this
compound stretches for miles and is home
to over 20 000 camels not all of them
will be winners over the next Fortnight
but there are 28 trophies at stake and
the top prize
foreign
Al Jazeera al-shahanya